الحين في اغنيه للجماهير يقول
ينادي باسم اللاعب مثلا فلان يقولون داخل
الملعب الحين كريم بنزيما حيكون داخل
الملعب هذا اللاعب الفرنسي الجزائري الاصل
الكريم بنزيما وصل الى وين الى الاتي الى
جده بعد توقيع عقد لمده ثلاث مواسم مع
نادي الاتحاد السعودي قادما من العشق ريال
مدريد
سعادتك مجروحه
ايضا مشاهدينا كان في استقبال النجم
الفرنسيه عدد كبير من الجماهير
والاعلاميين الذين تواجدوا في مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي يستعد نادي الاتحاد
التقديم بنزيما للجماهير في حفل ضخم اليوم
على ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله الرياضيه
كونوا
كثار جدا
مشجع راح متوقعين انه وكمان الحب والدعوه
عامه للجماهير الاتحاد وبلاش كمان مجانا
يا حلو جماهير الاتحاد وهي تشجع مع اني
انا ترى قبل كنت قبل كنت احب الاتحاد
الجماهير وتشجيعهم كان لطرب مختلف غير عن
بقيه يعني روابط المشجعين دائما لمتابعتي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات